- Just close your eyes until you're 29.
Everybody wants to come up with excuses.
I'm this, I wasn't born that way...
- I'm stuck, I'm in a rut.
- I wasn't born here, this.
You can't be lost in life
when you're this young.
I'm a female. I'm an immigrant.
I'm a minority.
I'm transgender.
Excuses.
Reality the problem is nobody cares.
Your lack of patience is killing you.
It's slowing you down and everybody else.
Your need of things is killing you.
I don't need a fucking watch.
I don't need a fucking whip.
You need to be happy 'cause
happiness drives everything.
You're not lost in life you're
just early in the process.
Everybody's trying to
prove something so early.
You fucking wrap your head
around not giving a fuck
about any advancement til you're 29.
Please whatever it takes
call your grandmother,
go to your great
grandfather's burial spot.
Go back to the old country.
Go to a shelter.
Do something.
Do something that
recalibrates your perspective
on what is actually going on here.
Every person in here
fucking won the lotto.
You won.
Way too many people have made decisions
without ever trying.
Everybody's judging
themselves way too early.
You can literally do four different things
over the next two years,
six months at a time
to figure out everything that
you think you might like,
you should try to do.
Doing something around passion
is very similar to love.
You're blinded because you like it.
- [Man] It's not rational.
- It's not rational.
The number one reason I push patience.
Patience, man. Patience.
Everybody's looking up to audit themselves
where they are now.
Is 'cause patience will give
you the air cover to take risk.
Time is your asset.
What I would do is gather as
many experiences as possible.
The one thing a 20 year old has
over me is 20 fucking years.
(laughing)
Get the fuck out of the
machine for a second.
And think about what you're doing here.
If you get optimism and patience,
you're fucking off to the fucking races.
The 99% that achieve are
willing to sacrifice,
be persistent, put in
disproportionate work,
and think in 50 year
terms not 50 day terms.
Just close your eyes until you're 29.